uh one of our favorite regulars in the
history of the show this guy fresh off
of a weekend of soldout theaters with me
lots of momentum uh Make some noise for
the Great and Powerful Hans Kim
everybody hey what's up
guys sad to hear that the great Matthew
Perry died alone in a hot tub you know
for a guy on a show called Fred he could
have used a
[Applause]
couple who knew the opening credits were
his Cry for
Help I recently ghosted a girl cuz she
was too
sunburned yeah she got left on
[Laughter]
red women are crazy we all know this
women are always into murder
documentaries they like to watch people
losing their life men were more positive
would you like to watch people creating
life thank
you hell yeah thank
you
welcome again Hans thank you Tony that
was fun how do you feel I feel great I
had a great weekend with you guys I uh
you know enjoyed our time together I I
think William might have a drinking
problem but other than that it was great
what do you mean uh he likes to drink a
lot and then he pees in little
bottles and there's like a bathroom
right there he just loves peeing in
bottles did he pee in a bottle he he uh
he tried to wait what do you mean when
we were in the car going to to
Sacramento when I stopped him you
stopped him yeah yeah no yeah I heard
that yeah they were way I was in the
front they were way way way in the back
of the Sprinter van and his I heard
Williams say to Hans like well what was
it exactly he was like can I pour some
of this in there yeah
like the drive it was only like an hour
and a half drive that's the crazy part
everybody's afraid a fun fact is that
everyone that tours with me is afraid to
say that they have to go pee because I
always say that slows us up I'm a real
[__] piece of [__] on the road I'm a
nightmare nightmare to deal with I don't
pee why are you peeing if I'm not peeing
and I'm like the main
guy red man as well he's a non-peer yeah
I could not pee for like 12 hours
exactly you got it's a podcast way
welcome to the business looks like
you've not been peeing for six
years you what you you're you're saying
the red band's filled with piss Jesus H
well you know he likes yellow things
whoa a reference to his Asian girlfriend
that's right oh my he's got he's got an
Asian girlfriend and he's got a white
girlfriend yeah it doesn't make any
sense we swap out once in a while but
okay all right Jesus
Christ Hans that when you when you
started dating your your white
girlfriend was that after you became
famous yes of
course and what happened before you were
famous I was sad and lonely that is true
and who made you famous Tony hinch that
is correct okay so the left un red thing
was a joke the Matthew Perry friends
thing was good thank you very good and
then what is it women watch murdered
documentaries and men watch porn okay do
you still watch porn I watch a lot of it
you do yes you watch it alone alone by
myself with my dick in my hand wow okay
yeah what's your favorite type of porn
probably tickling or spanking
or massage but what's your icon when it
says search what do you search for I
search for uh Japanese massage shrimp
aphrodisiac absolutely absolutely I love
it Hans business is a boomman for Hans
Kim you have more stuff coming up right
more dates I'm in Tacoma next week which
will already be over but uh ban coming
up and then uh you know other places
it's on my website go check it out
what's your website uh Bobby le.com
Jesus so it before we were when we were
upstairs I asked him if he brought his
girlfriend to The Warfield show this
weekend and you said what I said no I
cuz Tony said what cuz Tony he said not
cool dudes but then Tacoma what Tacoma
yes what are you asking him what are you
doing I asked the question questions you
sit back and hit a what did I say hit
what hit the button when it goes no no
oh the the Bear right again Paulie show
which you guys can be some of the first
viewers of I'm sure it's the jam in the
van show hosted by Paulie Shore you have
anything on YouTube you can watch why
not watch Paulie again the jam of the
band show
he I love you Paulie I'm just kidding
don't be sad no we're good all right
good it's [__] Monday night where I
killed Tony in [__] Austin
Texas yeah we got still a couple tickets
left for the stadium show over the um
January 1st who's
we who is we
paully Hans anything else you want to
say any more input um I was talking to
my British friend and he kept talking
about Peter files like they're not that
bad Peter files and I was like who's
Peter files and he's like oh it's
pedophiles so so oh wow that's like your
left on red joke right there that's a
little wow what was that yeah I don't
know what's happening Hans is getting a
little [__] corny without these
challenges and [__] are you ready for
Rick Diaz on New Year's Eve I'm ready
for
Rick [__] Rick [__] Rick the biggest
battle in Kill Tony history Hans Kim
versus Rick Diaz live New Year's Eve H
you did it again you got to start we got
to get to this bucket thank you so much
goes Hans Kim everybody
I'm going to preo your second
comedian and your first comedian out of
the bucket